well the war of words between President
Trump and fired FBI director James Comey
escalated new heights this week mr.
Trump lashed out against commis tell-all
book on Twitter calling him quote a
proven leaker and a liar all this as the
president's personal attorney Michael
Cohen is in a court battle to protect
evidence that could possibly be used
against him in a criminal investigation
which could also implicate the president
mola Lengai is at the White House with
the latest mullah good morning well good
morning we learned Friday that Cohen
negotiated yet another payoff top GOP
fundraiser Eliot broidy abruptly
resigned from his position at the
Republican National Committee after he
acknowledged that he paid 1.6 million
dollars to a former Playboy model after
she said that he got her pregnant but
the day began with the latest
revelations from James Comey I was
floating above myself looking down
saying you're sitting here briefing the
incoming president United States about
prostitutes in Moscow in his new memoir
former FBI director James Comey portrays
the President as obsessed with
disproving allegations the Russians had
filmed him with prostitutes in a Moscow
hotel room in a now infamous dossier
claims mr. Trump has denied I honestly
never thought these words would come out
of my mouth but I don't know whether the
current president United States with
with prostitutes peeing on each other in
Moscow in 2013 in the scathing book
Comey describes the Trump administration
as a forest fire calling the behavior he
witnessed disturbing but short of being
illegal President Trump fired back
calling Comey a weak and untruthful
slimeball the White House launched an
all-out attack the American people see
right through the blatant lies of a
self-admitted leaker all while the
president's personal lawyer Michael
Cohen is fighting to keep investigators
from seeing documents seized in a series
of raids at his home office and hotel
room Monday
federal prosecutors seized phones
computers financial documents and a
safety deposit box
it's a disgraceful situation it's a
total witch hunt agents also used search
warrants on multiple different email
accounts maintained by Cohen but
none were with President Trump they were
concerned some records could have been
deleted without record
sources say Cohen is known to tape
conversations with people some of the
evidence may include those recordings
Cohen has been under criminal
investigation for months zeroing in on
his personal business dealings he is
already under federal investigation for
paying one hundred thirty thousand
dollars to adult film star stormy
Daniels who alleged that she had a
sexual encounter with mr. Trump in 2006
the payment made shortly before the 2016
election could have violated campaign
finance laws Cohen's attorneys are
asking the judge to block the FBI to
protect evidence swept in the raids
citing attorney-client privilege stormy
Daniels attorney Michael avenatti
clearly Michael Cohen was his longtime
attorney and effectively probably knows
where all the bodies are buried as they
say and I think that in the event that
Michael Cohen is ultimately charged that
that could pose significant and very
very serious problems for the president
United States well yesterday the Justice
Department's internal watchdog released
a damning memo on commis former deputy
Andrew McCabe the report concludes that
McCabe mislead investigators multiple
times over his contacts with reporters
in 2016 leading to his firing on McCabe
like Comey kept detailed notes of
conversations with the president notes
that he has handed over to the special
counsel RIA mol the lanky at the White
House Thank You mola